anyone who is a fan of the Soul series
knows that the game poses more questions
than answers the same is true of the
information we have just received
regarding Dark Souls 2 the game's new
directors Tommy Hiro Shibuya and you e10
Amira answered questions in edge
magazine but ultimately we are left with
clues let's try to see what kind of game
these clues point towards and answer the
question should we be worried edge
magazine was shown a 10-minute
playthrough of Dark Souls 2 and said it
was a huge step forward graphically from
its predecessors it looks on par with
watchdogs and Star Wars 1313 and can
easily be considered a next-gen game
this is great news for PC gamers who
will not be held back by outdated
systems the graphics are said to be
shockingly close to the trailers quality
from software and Namco Bandai are
really pulling out all the stops of this
game according to Shibuya the team
working on Dark Souls 2 is substantially
bigger he points out that the studio has
nearly doubled the internal team focused
on world creation alone in addition to
adding new members across every
department the game is estimated at 25%
finished which means we can pretty much
rule out the game arriving in 2013 one
of the biggest gripes Miyazaki had with
the Dark Souls was that it required
patches and shipped incomplete and no
one is keen to make that mistake again
when we get the game it will be perfect
in the eyes of developer speaking of
developers many of you are aware that
the lead developers for Dark Souls 2
have changed the soul series was the
genius of hitter Takamiya Zaki who had
an interest in western fantasy and
mythology he built a dark world that
could be never completely understood a
concept which stemmed from his relative
inability to read English text as a
child he had to fill in the blanks with
his imagination and so do we
but miyazaki is no longer director he
will supervise the game but from the
article we can tell that he is truly
stepping aside and I quote in order to
steer Dark Souls in a fresh direction
Miyazaki is working on a new title as a
director but we have no information on
what this is as if you
Namco Bandai's recent attempts to
develop memorable new properties have
been largely unsuccessful from their
viewpoint it makes sense to give me as
our key a chance to replicate his genius
while handing the Sol series to a pair
of directors who aim to make the game
even more popular this is where I start
getting anxious the new directors Tama
heroes Shibuya and you e10 amira have
worked on titles such as Monster Hunter
& Armored Core they have a number of
good games under their belt and were
approved by Miyazaki himself shibuya
mentions that he wants to enhance the
action in the game and if the combat in
monster hunter is anything to go by I
wouldn't mind his enhancements I don't
believe we will be seeing major overall
to the combat or the core gameplay and
you must bear in mind that a different
director doesn't mean a different game
it will still feel like a Souls game
because of the team that works on it but
some key aspects of the game have been
pulled into question and the directors
have made some debatable statements this
is where we get our cause for concern
from reading the article I believe the
controls of the game won't change but we
will notice a change in direction that
will appeal to a wider audience
the directors say the experience won't
change and we just have to hope that the
extra accessibility will not infringe on
the experience Shibuya says he wants the
game to be more accessible this is a
scary word for souls fans because
accessible might be synonymous with easy
and easy is synonymous with casual games
however even I agree that the souls
games could explain some mechanics a bit
better world tendency and Demon Souls
was borderline impossible to figure out
without a wiki and summoning humanity
weapon requirements and covenants were
confusing in Dark Souls even though they
were core components of the game if a
new player runs through Dark Souls with
no knowledge of these things then they
will miss out on half the game through
no fault of their
the same goes for the law which I
learned through the community rather
than the games themselves I love the
fact that these things are hidden and
encouraged community but at the same
time I can appreciate why Namco wants to
make the game more understandable I
think that everyone can rest assured
that Shibuya feels the same way as he
promises that there will still be hidden
elements in the story and the world
which can be missed in the article
Shibuya talks about limiting player
options for the very first portion of
the game making it simpler to understand
the core gameplay concepts of this new
Dark Souls after a certain period of
time has elapsed players will
immediately feel the Dark Souls
experience and as long as that Dark
Souls experience is there I'm satisfied
Shibuya seems to want to reinforce and
reward understanding in the soul series
we see intuition rewarded a bridge with
bloodstains and burn marks on it means
you must progress cautiously and
realizing that there are ghosts ahead
means that you probably can't hit them
with your current equipment at the same
time there are hidden walls and covenant
effects that couldn't possibly be
understood without the help of a wiki in
the article Shibuya says he wants to
make us think further into what each
situation actually means when he says he
wants to make the game are accessible I
think this is what should be is
referring to he wants less ambiguity
more experiences and more rewards for
understanding he even mentions
implementing a system that will let you
reveal the clues you've learned over the
course of the game
I love the hidden parts of Dark Souls
and I hope the changes in Dark Souls to
invalidate the need to search the wiki
there's nothing wrong with more clues
and higher rewards for those who find
them this game from Asus drastic change
and that's something to be excited and
anxious about the excessive focus on
accessibility is cause for concern but
until we see gameplay it comes down to
faith in the developers remember that
everyone working on Dark Souls knows
what Dark Souls represents just as well
as we do I'm keen to see what an
unprecedented budget and new ambition
can do for the game and I foresee the
game becoming accessible because it is
addictive and enticing rather than
dumbed down and easy in closing I'd like
to formally thank Miyazaki for all he's
done there's a good chance he won't be
associated with the souls games for a
while and I speak for all viewers when I
say thank you thank you for Korea
a series that was innovative risky and
strayed away from the casualized path
most modern games follow thank you for
making games that inspired creativity
and community in myself and others
here's to the future of the souls games
and the future of the director that made
them he is - hoping that the fire won't
fade after the fire keeper is gone